[Musique]
imaginez que
un jour au matin ans qu'il vend vous
recevez dans votre boîte mail un message
qui vous dit que vous vous avez gagné un
voyage gratuit
n'importe où dans le monde déjà la suite
au bout c'est pas une arnaque c'est par
pur d'un brave coup d'envoi vous
condamniez c'est pas une arnaque
tout va bien rassurez vous donc vous
avez le droit d'aller n'importe où dans
le monde
vraiment n'importe où je disais tous
frais payés au tél tout est alors la
question tu est la première ville qui
vous vient à l'esprit
on voudrait voir et en premier sinon ap
totalement le choix sur cette vague
planète
alors je vais choisir quelques
participantes monsieur cabine d'un bébé
j'adore être une proposition
new york très bien ça monte oui monsieur
anvers en panne la barre monsieur vais
vous dire vous avez rêvé à dubaï très
bien à dubai world ou new york
on a des bébés monsieur hilaire la palud
et très bien très bien madame moore et
bruce vous avez le choix
ce n'est très bien ce qui est un peu
d'exercice c'est que 9 fois sur 10 vous
le fait est là encore l'un d'eux vicat
peut pas publier tous les styles nous
sommes dans la revue vous le faites
neuf fois sur dix vous aurez inutile
dans l'agression et ça crée un problème
c'est un problème pour vous parce que
nous ne nous imaginons par exemple
pouvoir habiter des espaces qui sont
elles ne prendront jamais hein pourquoi
pas abidjan tout un bébé ou à papa ligne
ou encore je penserai à
cette technique et moi
loin d'appareils très belle fille de
lointains ou encore abou dia mai
très bien pourquoi mardi est longue
quelle réalité que nous sommes
confrontés à d autres à six et dix ans
et qui montrent par exemple teurs
l'africain moyen vivre un espace qu'il
fera le 6 et le 8 ans nous allons vivre
dans l'oeil d'un sens de prolongement de
l'europe de l'occident aux états unis
nous pensons à usc new yor peloton dubaï
exemple ne vivons pas mentalement en
afrique
bruno la fin de vie comme on dit
autrement c'est comme si dans le texte
où tous nous avions les veilles dames
nous sommes sur le tarmac brède
déguerpir à n'importe quel moment à la
ville aux gagnants nous sommes prêts à
partir
le problème tout ça pose c'est comment
on ne peut pas créer de la postérité
comme sur une terre qu'on veut quitter
ça vous aurez vu ça n'existe pas il
n'existe pas d'exemple dans l'histoire
ou en crée de la richesse du bien-être
et du bonheur sur une paire pour fuir ou
à ce qu'on a vu ça alors les paradoxes
auquel seuls avec cela c'est aussi le
fait par exemple que là où tous les
grands pays toutes les grandes
puissances du monde travaille à élargir
leur pacte de l'existence le train de
vie leur domaine des flux ans nous en
afrique nous avons encore des
espace et niété togo bénin ghana côte
d'ivoire nigeria au mot même s'il est
immense le lieu comme oh ça reste
l'espace fille était sur le continent
gigantesque
vous avez donc d imaginer avisés et qui
explique par exemple que quand les
américains qu'ils ont une illustre
exemple et c'est un genre de détendre
les enfants économique avec l'europe à
travers le tact à paris ou du d'unifier
le plus le continent nord américain
parle de l'alena nous en sommes encore
ici à barboter dans le vieux couvent il
est également de chenal qui depuis 50
ans n'a pas beaucoup avancé
alors tous les pays y ont leurs projets
par l'afflux terme tous chine afrique
europe afrique i am et la plus israël
afrique israël afrique
et ça ça me frappe comme un coup de
poing contre eux quelque part il ya lien
rien petit problème si des gens qui sont
agréables parce que les chinois
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont à respecter
si les échanges de ce calibre en france
à fric qu'est ce que vous attendez vous
vous même pour penser afrique après
l'afrique
comment se fait-il que français plane à
10 entre l'anglais et l'enfant se
fatiguent
par ailleurs est beaucoup plus de
facilité on voit errer sur mon continent
comme moi même comment se fait il que
ceci se passe fort là me donne beaucoup
beaucoup moins de faste et pouvoiristes
sur mon continent comme un sport
français anglais c'est le labourier ou
chinois bien que je suis papa dans leurs
hommes de dieu c'est vrai
et là vous fait ce qu'on fait là où ça
d'un peu loin quand on y réfléchit c'est
que l'on pouvait imaginer meilleur que
le togolais béninois le congolais deux
botswanais son imaginaire et restreints
qu'à son espace et ce qui est à moi qui
suis écrivain par exemple qui travaille
sur les images créées
là où je travaille c'est votre qui ce
que je suis encore plus heureux dieu
décide petite panne de succès parce qu'à
mes yeux les personnages ce qui me
frappe c'est que vous rendre votre la
plupart des choses que nous prouvons
pondéré et tangible des frontières où la
marée pages ne sont pas des perceptions
des conventions justement des
imaginaires partager l'exemple le plus
trivial serait par exemple de l'abonné
la monnaie ne mange pas on doit faire du
feu avec groupe si variés ça va bouger
pendant deux minutes mais pas deux
minutes 20 novembre d'après disparu mais
la monnaie de la valeur parce qu' un
certain nombre de personnes dur
reconnaît cette valeur vous partagez un
imaginaire dans lequel ce bout de papier
avec cette inscription dessus permet
d'acheter des dettes
tél c'est par exemple la gd ulrich loin
ici a donné ça sert à rien en cause une
étape et la conversion en service si
vous ne voyez pas et cède avec les votes
loyers ou les sens avec ça demain au
marché vous allez très vite comprendre
ce drame
ça peut être abstrait me fait
extrêmement lourd et ça nous a peut être
partout à tout instant le zümo vide du
coup que faire face à un départ lorsque
sa voiture
nous devons créer un imaginaire partager
les marges et mallié partagé pour qui
pour nous africains et tant d'autres
espaces de vie s'est étendue imaginer
c'est allé plus loin que les séquences
elle s'inquiète car locaux par exemple
aller plus loin voir que le vin plus
grands ne voyait pas juste affronter le
voit la griffe noire et l'autre ville
encore et l'autre pied juste je vais de
la quantique juste comme ça pourquoi pas
et donc voilà l'afrique monde
nous devons commencer à penser de la cré
comme contourne les asiatiques chez eux
dans la vie comme monde des européens
pensent de l'europe comme l'europe
montrent d'abord quand les européens
parlent
départ l'une au dessus des lettres pour
le nord c'est normal et le sucre et
l'espagne hall le sud sud sud pas
vraiment le fils pense pas à glaner ce
beau parce que son monde c'est l'europe
l'américain fondront dans la salle
amérique avant mission de penser à un
peu d'internet
l'individu moyen en asie en afrique et
en europe il a un monde dans lequel il
noue ce projet où ils respirent et où ce
projet nous devons créer des imaginaires
partagé en a pris cinq meilleures cotes
le malien le congolais le sud-africain
coin pour le canton et doivent partager
tes stats indiqué la lafa doivent vivre
en bout et comme nous projetons nous on
brade en premier voire new york ou paris
mais mine d'oak dogon ou tunis et c'est
ça dans le titre de l'un incarnant nous
faisons quand jeanne rose horizon de
possibilités pour l'entrepreneur par
exemple le business man qui est bloqué
dans un évident que les choses ne vont
pas le droit de garder une vente des
ingénieurs des architectes immense terre
mais pas besoin d'aller à paris pour ça
que tu as tu sûr d'avoir cherché sur ce
foutu continent signent un pas quelqu'un
quelque part qui a cette compétence qui
est sûr que le faire il fait venir de
chine à prix d'or tu peux pas le faire
venir le sens que j'ai plus loin de la
surprend pas candidats en es tu sûre
étant d'horizon nous on compte beaucoup
disent que nous prend pas des vignes le
problème n'existe pas nous devons parisé
les frontières pour
comme meilleur qu'attendu à posséder a
parlé plus haut crépon
il ne s'agit pas uniquement de le battre
cinq ans orthodoxe shass de boxe
nous devons changer le cas de montages
dans lequel nous portons notre espace
c'est très abstrait mais en même temps
vous voyez c'est quand même des choses
changeront de calme et l'a donc proposé
vous irez vous propose un petit thé
exercices là auront des de servir à ce
nouveau travail dans la nouvelle
entreprise et on les attend alors
imaginez vous êtes un pays africain
n'est pas que les pays agissent car si
les initient des togolais rpt est
d'actualité je voulais venir plus
aguerris dans le dos peillac imaginaire
aux frontières le contour bébéto sommes
tous voila vous l'avez en tête mais dans
l'imaginaire des frontières sept ans
vous grossissez au concile partie nord
sud est ouest vous vous élargissez vous
élargissez encore et encore 100 km 200
km 300 km mm d'un côté vous seule la
cantine vous arrêtez de l'autre vous
toucher l'océan indien vous arrêter vous
descendez veaux issus vous remplissez
seul espace ouvrir la question qu'avez
vous ressenti
que ressent-on quand vous sentez de
l'espace buzz un peu devant le togo la
côte d'ivoire auquel vous avez vous
regretté me présenter une carte espace
élargi cédant jusqu'à toucher la merde
et à la mise à pleurer
je sais ce que je ressens quand on me le
fait de rentrer les ferrand pour
enrôlement et ça c'est chic
bienvenue chez sas et la poutre et ce
destin c'est quoi tu y mets des états
unis de la chine de l'inde de l'europe
de l'ouest de l'europe de l'est
ouais ça c'est le demande le père qui
est dans mon madagascar
tu mets tout ça ayant assez de place
pour mettre quoi peut-être une dizaine
de topo dans sa chair vanille sécher
c'est notre espace c'est la crise et pas
de prison samedi dont tout le monde rêve
a donc fait 30 millions d'hectares et
qui a du soleil tout le temps de la
verdure de l'eau ou jaune le paradis il
est grand temps que nous attendions nous
avons de la place de l'espace dans mon
peuple nom des gens il est temps que
nous faisions tout honneur à sac
cette merveilleuse offert gratuitement
alors la vision qui va nous guider à
partir de là c'est quoi
elle est double pensée notamment en
termes de continence l'appel à
continentalité c'est à dire que en
afrique pas le pogo le pénal des crédits
et post coloniale mais l'afrique comme
une vaste sphère d'une circulation où on
respire on est libre de bouger c'est à
dire que je vais le dakar à luanda à
nouakchott la maladie à kampala
je vais saluer présente vous l'avez dit
maintenant à la retraite et du mesurage
des blagues simple je veux saluer tous
ces gens si bon que ça se voit et en 2d
l'insularité c'est à dire que nous
devons autant outre ouvert de
l'extérieur autant de moindre acte
d'amour permet un crabe de mode termine
sur l'extérieur parce qu il est
dangereux et ça le coup de pied contré
de faire trop de libre échange
de trop tant prime quand on ne maîtrise
pas contre des camions nourrissons de
moins d'un tireur en forçant des élus
restent alors on finir je vais vous
parler un peu de vision du monde et de
comment se présente le monde
comment des choses aussi anodines comme
accord occulte artres par exemple eu
dire que tout ça vous avez l'impression
de 2014
pourquoi toute cette saga c'est le
rendra le bar le sud l'est l'ouest les 5
en finance
ça c'est la prison de verre 14 on voit
l'afrique tranquille le lac
je pense que nous connaissons bien que
tous cette taxe si les plaques des
refuges l'abolition de mercator a été
produite par les occidentaux pour des
besoins de plus de navigation ils ont
fait un très bon travail et je me
retrouvais pour eux la catho répondant à
elle augmenté la taille dpx qui sont aux
extrêmes et à réduire la taille des pays
qui sont protégés de l'équateur ce qui
donne des étrangetés comme ça où on a
presque l'impression que le groenland
qui est tout blanc au a quasiment la
taille de l'afrique sont frappées de
trentels quand l'univers du programme
ans alors qu'on a évité la ne vous avez
envers la carte des pays avec leur
taille en version vous pouvoir allier de
la différence tu penses que ton quand
quelqu'un à sa cause en mai de la loi
sacrée demandant de faire encore mieux
sincèrement ça c'est l'afrique qui a un
sens et ça c'est notre vision
cette importance au temps des pays du
sud vers votre alors sept ans je les
aime bien parce que si tu étais
prévention pourquoi est-ce que je
n'aurais pas ça chez moi pourquoi mon
petit frère y ait un collège leur
passage dans son livre de géographie
nous sommes au son du monde et en
définitive pour finir la question c'est
où devront choisir entre ça et ce à
quelques secondes puis je sais c'est
qu'elle peut faire cher ami et montre la
fin
[Musique]